[Music]
okay today we have the new
$550 GeForce RTX 5070 the GPU that
Nvidia Jensen told us during their CES
keynote would be delivering RTX 4090
performance and that's the previous
generation Flagship that they charged at
least
$1600 us for hang on B you're at CS did
did they actually yeah yeah he said that
th this is meant to be equal to a 49
yeah all right this is all right hang on
a second I'll
just you know what I don't think this is
actually going to do it for this review
um
okay come with
me come on
okay so after the announcement our
social media accounts were blowing up
they were flooded with users celebrating
just how exciting this next generation
was going to be 490 performance for $550
us that sounds pretty amazing to me
today's video is brought to you by the
AOC q27 G3 xmn a fantastic bang for
buuck 1440p True HDR gaming monitor the
q27 g3xn regularly features in our best
1440p monitor roundups due to its mini
LED local dimming providing an
outstanding contrast ratio and great
image quality for HDR gaming it also has
a 180 HZ refresh rate over 1,000 nits of
peak brightness and a great budget
friendly price point we highly recommend
the AOC q27 g3xn and it's now available
not just in North America but other
locations worldwide including Australia
so to learn more and upgrade your gaming
setup to HDR today check the link in the
description below of course the
excitement was quickly squashed after it
became clear Nvidia was using multiframe
generation to make these extremely
misleading claims we were quick to point
this out in our CES coverage but still
many came away from the Nvidia
announcement expecting great things from
the RTX 5070 and now we finally have it
and boy is it super underwhelming the
RTX 5070 is just so boring underwhelming
it really just point
so I'm going to shorten I review I have
conducted extensive testing but I'm not
going to go over all of the individual
game data it becomes highly repetitive
and none of it is particularly exciting
but firstly what I want to deal with is
nvidia's big old lie the one that I just
mentioned where they proudly claimed
that the RTX 5070 would deliver 4090
performance obviously this is a massive
lie and it's a damaging one that hurts
features like frame Generation by
weaponizing it to mislead gaming is in a
nutshell multiframe generation is just a
more advanced version of single frame
generation instead of generating one
frame it can generate up to three frames
which increases smoothness provided your
monitor has a high enough refresh rate
to show those
frames what it doesn't do is increase
performance that's because unlike
rendering more normal frames creating
generated frames doesn't lower latency
in fact if anything the overhead of
creating the generated frames makes
worse latency so no reduction in latency
and no performance increase the game
won't feel or play any faster but it
will look smoother with some artifacts
thrown in so in a nutshell it's just
frame smoothing not a genuine
performance boost so again generating
frames does not boost performance and
therefore no matter how many frames you
generate the RTX 5070 cannot become
faster than an RTX 490 those kinds of
comparisons have to be made prior to an
aing frame generation so let's quickly
do that now so in reality the RTX 490 is
actually on average 63% faster than the
RTX 5070 across our 16 game sample at
1440p but the LIE gets even worse when
we turn on rate racing as here we find
examples where the RTX 5070 doesn't work
at all due to the much more limited 12
GB vram buffer one such example would be
Indiana Jones and the great Circle a
game Tim strongly recommended that I go
and add it to my RT testing Suite as the
game uses path tracing and looks really
great when doing so resulting in a truly
transformative experience so I went
about adding it to this latest round of
GPU testing but the only problem at
least for the RTX 5070 is that it can't
actually run the game under these
conditions rendering just 13 FPS on
average while the old 4070 TI super was
good for 47 FPS and this is due to the
fact that the new RTX 5070 a $550 GPU
being released in the year 2025 only
comes with a measly 12 GB vram buffer
and this is the kind of memory capacity
we would have hoped by now was reserved
only for entry-level products and that
an RTX 5070 would at minimum include 16
GB unfortunately that's not the case as
a result in this example the RTX 490 is
faster and frame generation can't even
fake enough frames to win here for the
RTX 5070 in fact if you were to enable
frame generation I imagine the RTX 5070
would be even worse because frame
generation requires more vram so that's
going to be a big problem and also be
aware this isn't even at Native 1440p we
are enabling dlss quality upscaling to
try and boost the performance and I
should note you can't even load the game
at 4K using these quality settings and
IM immediately crashes to
desktop so already things are looking
pretty bad for the RTX 5070 and while
you could certainly argue the gForce 50
Series has been a flop so far whatever
you think of the 90 80 and 5070 TI I can
tell you all three of those products are
much better than the 5070 and for those
who aren't up to speed with what the
5070 is let's quickly go over the specs
for $550 you're getting a Blackwell GPU
with $
6,14 four cicor 192 texture mapping
units and probably 80 RS so that's 31%
fewer cores than the 5070 TI and just 4%
more than the original RTX 4070 released
2 years ago now interestingly it's also
14% fewer cores than the updated RTX
4070 super and the core clock speed is
much the same but making up for the lack
of cores is potentially a 33% increase
in memory bandwidth as the RTX 5070 uses
28 gbits per second gddr 7 memory on a
192bit wide memory bus for a bandwidth
of 672 GB per so 14% fewer course than
the 470 super but 33% more memory
bandwidth and an 8% discount to the
MSRP but as I've already noted a
critical attribute that goes unchanged
is memory capacity like the original RTX
470 as well as the update dated 4070
super the RTX 570 only features a 12 GB
vram buffer so while the vram is
certainly faster the capacity Remains
the Same and no speed SL bandwidth can't
compensate for capacity it just doesn't
work that way so then it's sounding very
much like the 5070 is really just a 470
super with $50 knocked off the MSRP but
of course I've tested a lot of games to
confirm this so let's take a look at
some of of them and then we'll go over
the graphs breaking down the full
performance starting with Marvel Rivals
at 1440p we see the RTX 570 is a mere 3%
faster than the 4070 super and just 15%
faster than the 2-year-old RTX 470 I
haven't had a chance to update my 7900
gr data just yet but when compared to
the 7800 XT the 5070 is 16% faster and
then 6% slower than the 7900 XT then
moving up to 4K we set the 570 and 470
super in neck and neck delivering
virtually identical performance with
just 44 FPS on
average next up we have stalker 2 and
here the 5070 actually manages to be
slower than the 4070 super coming in 9%
slower at
1440p this meant it was also just 11%
faster than the 7800 XT and 12% slower
than the 7900 XT the 4K data is slightly
better but even so it best you could say
the 5070 managed to match the 470 super
here with just 33 FPS on average so it
all seems a bit
pointless moving on to Counter Strike 2
we're looking at very similar results
once again the RTX 5070 is essentially
an RTX 470 super as both delivered near
enough to identical performance at
1440p the 5070 did pull slightly ahead
of 4K but even so that saw it offering a
mere 6% performance uplift the Punk 2077
results at 1440p saw the 5070 com in
slightly behind the 4070 super though
we're talking about just a 2 FPS deficit
when comparing the average frame rate
still that meant the new 5070 was just
7% faster than the 7800 XT in this
example again the 5070 does perform a
little bit better relative to the 4070
super at 4K pulling ahead by a 6% margin
here with 51 FPS on average and this is
without any RT effects enabled and in
fact we're using the second highest
rasterization preset Hogwarts Legacy is
a very bandwidth sensitive game so this
does help the RTX 570 out a bit and at
1440 P it did end up beating the 470
super by an impressive 21% margin so
under the right conditions there are
some nice gains to be had though I
should also note that this did only see
the 5070 match the 7800
XT now oddly the margin did come down
quite substantially at 4K and as the
55070 is only 8% faster than the 470
super along with the 7800 XT with 66 FPS
on average The Last of Us Part One has
more typical results for us and that is
to say that at 1440p the RTX 570 is a
4070 super both delivering around 90 FPS
making the 5070 just 2% faster than the
7800 XT the 5070 performs a little bit
better at 4K though the average frame
frame rate was just 4% greater than that
of the 4070 super so very disappointing
performance overall the last game I'm
going to bother looking at the results
for is Starfield and this is yet another
example where the 4070 super is able to
outperform the new 5070 at 1440p granted
performance is much the same but it's
still very disappointing to see the 5070
coming in 3% slower even at 4K the 5070
ends up 6% slower than the 47 super with
just 45 FPS on average so again very
disappointing
results now 1440p across the 16 games
tested the RTX 570 was on average 1%
faster than the 470 super so I guess
that settles it really the 5070 is
basically a 4070 super which means
realistically for this to be a next
Generation GPU it should really be
called the 5060 but we've been down this
path already with the 50 70 TI the 80
and to a certain extent the 5090 which
really should have been called a 4090 TI
and it's much the same story at 4K here
the RTX 5070 was on average just 5%
faster than the 470 super delivering
3090 light performance so maybe Jensen
meant that the 5070 was going to deliver
3090 performance not 490 performance so
maybe he just misspoke or something like
that yeah that has to be it
surely now I'm not going to dive into
the power consumption stuff too much
here as power usage is boring at the
best of times and I know you won't
believe it but the 5070 is also a 470
super when it comes to power usage
consuming roughly the same level of
power across the games that we bothered
to
check now for the r tracing benchmarks
we'll start with Metro Exodus where the
5070 match the 470 super at 1440p well
it was 4% faster which is quickly
starting to feel like a good win for the
new GeForce GPU it was also 8% faster at
4K rendering 53 FPS on average which I'd
say is an embarrassing level of
performance for a $550 us gForce GPU
released in 2025 but of course the radon
gpus are even worse though none of them
were released this year so I guess
that's some sort of takeaway for Radon
gpus next up we have the Allen wake 2
performance and the 5070 sucks at 1440p
with upscaling only matching the
original 4070 making it 15% slower than
the 4070 super so that's a bit of a
disaster and we're only looking at 39
FPS on average increase in the
resolution to 4K with quality upscaling
enbl did allow the 5070 to match the 470
super but now we're looking at just 22
FPS on average so it's not really a win
then is it moving on to cyberpunk 2077
the RTX 570 continues its run of
extremely underwhelming rage racing
performance this time coming in 12%
slower than the 470 super with 58 FPS on
average oddly once again we see the 5070
is only able to match the 4070 super
once we reach the 4K resolution or
rather 4K with quality upscaling but
we're now looking at just 31 FPS on
average so hardly acceptable performance
the Spider-Man remaster results at 1440p
are CPU limited but even so the 5070
wound up 14% faster than the 470 super
and like we saw in Hogwarts Legacy this
is another game that's very bandwidth
sensitive so that explains why the 5070
does so much better here that said there
is some other limitation at 4K as here
the 5070 is knocked down to 470 super
light performance which is still great
performance overall with 91 FPS but it's
also very unimpressive when compared to
previous generation Parts the RTX 5070
was able to just nudge ahead of the 4070
super In Dying Light 2 though only by a
5% margin we're also looking at similar
margins at 4K here the 5070 was a mere
7% faster with 44 FPS on average so
certainly nothing to get excited about
the RTX 570 is back to being an RTX 470
super in black myth Wukong just 46 FPS
at 1440p with upscaling but at least
it's not a radon GPU I guess then at 4K
with upscaling enabled the RT X 570 is
completely useless only matching the RTX
470 super with 25
FPS then we have Indiana Jones in the
great circle which was a late addition
to this review but I'm glad Tim
suggested I include it to show off the
RT performance of these new GeForce gpus
because doesn't it just paint a lovely
picture for the 12 GB RTX 5070 just 13
FPS on average at 1440p with upscaling
of course you can dial down the quality
settings to avoid filling up the memory
buffer but these are the r tracing
settings that Tim recommends you'll want
to use for a truly transformative
experience in this title naturally then
4K is out of the question and it's
really out of the question as the game
will crash and then refuse to relaunch
on a 12 GB GPU without using the safe
mode and then refuse to relaunch on a 12
GB GPU with full RT enabled you will
have to load back in using the safe mode
option and then lower the settings so
how f future proof is the RT performance
of the RTX 5070 and maybe just
performance in general with these new 12
GB gpus in
2025 I'd say not vary by the looks of
things now because the RTX 5070
completely crapped out in Indiana Jones
in the great circle with full RT enabled
I've removed that game from the average
as we calculate using a geom mean and
that's left us with just six titles this
still saw the 5070 come in just behind
the RTX 470 super
though it's fair to say performance
overall was identical then at 4K it's
slightly faster than the 4070 super
though again performance overall really
was near enough to call identical and
even with the help of upscaling frame
rates were generally very
poor now in a perfect world where the
MSRP actually meant something the RTX
5070 would actually be a decent value
product dare I say it and that's of
course if you look past the obvious vram
limitations this product which will no
doubt become a much larger issue over
the coming years but ignoring that real
issue I guess the 5070 at $550 us looks
pretty good certainly not amazing but
yeah we'll go with good it's 8% better
value than the 570 TI and 20% better
value than the RTX 580 though of course
both of those products do come with more
vram and while it might only be the
minimum amount of vrm we want to see on
these mid-range to high-end products s
but at least those products do meet what
we consider to be the minimum it's also
133% better value than the RTX 470 super
so again not an amazing gen on- gen
uplift there but if available at the
MSRP it Stacks up pretty well in an MSRP
World however the RTX 470 super did see
some small discounts applied in 2024 so
if you're bought back then the RTX 5070
only ends up being 10% better value and
I think I'd rather give up 10% for 6 to
12 months of use making an RTX 47 new
super purchase about a year ago uh the
preferable choice in my opinion now the
RTX 570 will have to contend with the
radon RX
970 so I think chances are we will see
it hit that $550 us MSRP sooner rather
than later that said here in Australia
the RTX 570 is expected to cost at least
,250 Australian dollar which is a very
poor price point as that makes it 8%
more expensive in terms of cost per
frame when compared to the RTX 4070
super which you could buy recently for
$1,100 it also makes the RTX 5070 worse
value than Parts such as the radon RX
7900 XTX 7900 XT and significantly worse
than the 7800 XT in fact the cost per
frame R compared to the 7800 XT is is
31% higher that's for a card with less
vrm so that's obviously very bad now
before we wrap this review up just
quickly here's how nvidia's found aition
version of the RTX 5070 compared to the
Asus Prime and gigaby Eagle Under full
load the Fe model hit a peak GPU
temperature of 72° whereas the eagle was
much cooler at just 63° and then just
62° for the prime it was a similar story
when it comes to memory temps the Fe
model ran at 76° whereas the eagle
peaked it to 64° and the prime at
68° now quite oddly the Fe model was
reporting a fan speed of
2,350 RPM though it didn't seem loud
enough to be operating at that speed
given the operating volume was 39 DB
typically with this kind of fan speed we
expect the noise to be comfortably over
40 DB still the eagle and Prime were
much quieter at 35 and 34 DB
respectively
now the eagle did consume 20 WTS less
than the Fe model which saw a clock
almost 2% lower at
2,760 MHz so it's a bit odd that this is
the OC version of the eagle and yet it
clocks lower than nvidia's reference
model we also saw a similar thing with
the prime though and although power
consumption was reported to be higher we
still saw a slightly lower core clock
frequency okay so if you can't tell I'm
personally not a fan of the GeForce RTX
50 7 it's a compromised product that
will struggle to Leverage The RTX
feature set due to its limited 12 GB
vram buffer and although that might not
be a significant issue right now I
expect will be within the realistic
lifespan of this product as for the
general performance it's nothing special
the RTX 5070 is basically a refreshed
RTX 470 super with $50 knocked off the
MSRP for whatever that's worth it can
rub shoulders with the RTX 47 super at
times but again with just 12 GB of vram
it's not a favorable comparison overall
realistically you would have just been
better off buying an RTX 470 Super 6 to
12 months ago if you wanted this level
of performance from a GeForce GPU 6
months ago it was just $585 us readily
available and if you want to go back 12
months it was available for
$600 so waiting 12 months to maybe save
$50 for a 5% performance boost hardly
seems worth it which is why the RTX 5070
is so extremely
underwhelming but for those of you
looking at spending around $550 us right
now on a GPU there really isn't a better
option well that is until the 970 series
is released tomorrow from AMD the RX 970
is said to cost $550 us and AMD are
confident they can deliver models at
that price the RX 970 could end up being
faster it certainly offers more vram so
with our detailed analysis along with a
dedicated look at FSR 4 coming up on the
channel very shortly I imagine it'll pay
to wait just a little bit to see which
$550 GPU is really worth your money
though I suspect spending the extra $50
on the 9070 XT is going to be the real
answer so make sure you're subscribed
for those upcoming videos and that is
going to do it for this one in a
nutshell the 5070 has impress us if you
can't tell in fact it's very
underwhelming though you've probably got
that as well anyway we're going to have
to wait and see what AMD has for us
before making any recommendations at
this price point that said we have heard
that the RTX 5070 availability is
virtually non-existent so reviews aside
if you want to buy a GPU right now you
might have to buy a 9070 series product
anyway of course we will have to review
that one for you tomorrow so you can
purchase with all the necessary
information you don't have to just guess
there or do any crazy pre-order stuff
the reviews are just around the corner
in the meantime please like this video
if you found it useful you can subscribe
because as I said we have more videos
coming up and then we have the join
button and patreon but other than that I
am done with this highly disappointing
review of well the hopefully the review
wasn't disappointing the 5070 was anyway
it's getting pretty Breezy pretty cold
up here so I'm going to go get off the
roof now and go back to my nice warm
cozy studio I'll catch you next time
[Music]